الاطفال هم الفئه الاضعف في الصراعات وهذا
ينطبق بالطبع على نزاع في السودان ترى نحو
اثنين وثمانين الف طفلا الى الدول
المجاوره واصبح
368 الف اخرين نازحين داخليا منذ بدء
النزاع الاطفال الذين لا يزالون في
السودان يعيشون محنه
رهيبه بحسب مديره يونيسف في السودان اطفال
السودان يعانون اضطراب ما بعد الصدمه ونقل
بعده بعضهم للمستشفيات النفسيه داخل
السودان فيما دشنت مصر مثلا وحدات دعم
نفسيا للاطفال تضم عيادات متنقله وثابته
على المعابر الحدوديه بهدف تقديم الدعم
النفسي للاطفال والمراهقين والعلاج المبكر
لما يسمى بامراض النزوح
فجاه فجاه من غير اي مقدمات بس سمعنا
اصوات ضرب
[موسيقى]
بس كده قاعدين خايفين
تقيم في اي لحظه ممكن نفقد واحد مننا
نفسيا جسديا في منا عيانين المرضى وما
عندنا علاج لفي اكيد البيض الاكل برضو
ينقص في البيت
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات